[Music]
the stars aligned for beyonce's 41st
birthday literally a who's who of
hollywood attending the superstar's
b-day bash in los angeles
[Music]
and this party gave us total gold member
vibes thanks to bee's theme a 70s roller
disco so legendary a blonde kim
kardashian snagged an invite putting
rumors to rest that beyonce isn't a fan
looking groovy in a red and black
striped cat suit
girl kim strutted in with her girls sis
chloe and bestie lala anthony also in
sparkly ensembles
chloe shared these pics of the trio
giving a nod to one of b's biggest hits
with the caption
hey i'm single
inside the ladies rubbed elbows with the
likes of offset who wore a glittery
michael jackson inspired fit and drake
who went for full comfort in a velvet
tracksuit and even showed off what we're
assuming were party favors custom socks
then there's vanessa bryant who brought
her daughter natalia as her date as for
the other attendees seemed like a date
night that had them
yeah lizzo brought boyfriend mike wright
they posed for picks in their gucci
party gear and here's hallie bailey and
her guy wearing matching adidas track
suits they stepped into the photo booth
for this sweet snapshot she is just wow
meanwhile megan fox and machine gun
kelly showed up hand in hand and snuck
these sultry pics shushing all that
split speculation whatever daddy says
and then there were the a-listers who
were able to avoid the cameras like
adele and her boyfriend rich paul bella
hadid jaden smith kris jenner chloe's ex
tristan thompson and lily rose death i
just hope everyone loves it even the
birthday girl managed to steer clear of
the paparazzi which probably only added
to how much fun she was able to have at
the star-studded event it's pretty
amazing
[Music]
you